bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va pas m de la mauvaise
foi
on pourrait croire de prime alors que la
mauvaise foi n'est pas vraiment une
question philosophique que c'est plutôt
une question psychologique
mais on va voir aujourd'hui que c'est
une question qu'on peut traiter sous
l'angle de la philosophie c'est ce qu'a
fait jean paul sartre dans un ouvrage
intitulé l'être et le néant un ouvrage
assez difficile d'accès mais absolument
indispensable pour comprendre sa vision
du monde
est ce que ça te rappelle la mauvaise
foi ce n'est pas tout à fait la même
chose que ce qu'on appelle couramment la
mauvaise foi
même s'il ya un point commun même s'il y
a un mécanisme commun
et c'est ce mécanisme que je vais tenter
de vous décrire aujourd'hui
alors déjà commençons par parler de la
mauvaise foi au sens courant
au sens courant la mauvaise foi c'est
l'attitude qui consiste à nier la
réalité
c'est l'attitude qui consiste
à soutenir une idée à soutenir une
opinion que l'on sait être fausse que
l'on sait être contraire à la vérité
parce que la vérité ne nous arrange pas
on est de mauvaise foi quand on nie la
vérité
non pas parce qu'on l'ignorent mais
justement parce qu'on la connaît
assumer
parce qu'elle va à l'encontre de nos
intérêts
de quels intérêts bien c'est ce qu'on va
voir
mais notons déjà une chose intéressante
qui est que la mauvaise foi à la
différence du mensonge ne vise pas
seulement à convaincre l'autre
elle vise à se convaincre soi même
l'individu de mauvaise foi c'est celui
qui tente de se mentir à lui-même
quand on mord à quelqu'un on ne cherche
pas à se convaincre soi même de son
mensonge
on cherche à convaincre l'autre
alors que dans la mauvaise foi on a
besoin de croire dans son mensonge
on sait au fond nous que ce qu'on dit
est faux
mais on essaye quand même
on a besoin d'y croire
quitte à rouen la réalité
et pour bien vous montrer ses
différences entre le mensonge et la
mauvaise foi on va prendre un exemple
vous êtes invités à manger chez vos
beaux-parents
belle maman a fait un pot-au-feu et sauf
que belle maman n'a pas laissé la viande
cuir assez longtemps
et du coup ben c'est pas bon
le problème c'est que vous n'avez pas du
tout envie de lui dire que c'est pas bon
parce que ça se fait pas parce que vous
avez été bien éduqué et que vous avez
appris qu on ne crache pas sur la main
qui nous nourrit
qu'est ce que vous allez dire
vous allez rien dire
en espérant que belle maman on va
l'appeler corinne en espérant corinne ne
vous demande pas si c'était bon
et évidemment au bout d'une minute quand
on pose la question fatidique
ça vous plaît
c'est délicieux corinne
je vais juste de sel mais c'est
délicieux
ça c'est un mensonge
ce qu'on appelle un pieux mensonge
mais la mauvaise foi c'est pas tout
chose
la mauvaise foi c'est quand vous êtes
dans la voiture retour que votre femme
vous dit que le pot-au-feu été ratée et
que vous lui dites ah tu exagères
moi j'ai trouvé ça bon et cuisine très
bien corinne
ça c'est la mauvaise foi
c'est la mauvaise foi parce que là vous
essayez de vous convaincre vous même de
votre mensonge
dans le mensonge dans le mensonge pur il
ya au moins l'honnêteté de ne pas en
rajouter
alors que dans la mauvaise foi il y as
persistance dans le mensonge au delà de
la nécessité
on ne manque plus pour se tirer
d'affaires on ment
une pas la réalité de ce qu'on pense
mais votre connaît bien et lcl que vous
êtes de mauvaise foi
elle vous dira d'ailleurs
c'est bon tu peux le dire un mois
c'était pas bon
et s'il avoue continuer à dire que
c'était bon si vous faites mine de ne
pas être d'accord avec votre femme
parce que vous avez décrété qu'il
fallait dire que c'était bon même si ça
n'était pas vous êtes dans la mauvaise
foi
la différence entre le mensonge et la
mauvaise foi c'est que le mensonge et
d'assumer comme mensonge
il est assumé comme mensonge par notre
conscience
on sait que ce qu'on dit est faux quand
on ment
alors que la mauvaise foi c'est la
surcouche
d'autopersuasion c'est la surcouche
d'auto aliénation par laquelle on
cherche à intégrer notre mensonges dans
la réalité
un peu comme une pièce de puzzle qui ne
semblerait pas et qui fait qu'au lieu de
changer la pièce on va changer le puzzle
pour que ça puisse rentrer
le puzzle c'est la réalité
changer le puzzle c'est modifier la
réalité pour que notre mensonges n'en
soit plus un
va prendre un autre exemple qui va nous
permettre d'aller un peu plus loin
imaginez que vous connaissez quelqu'un
qui a fait quelque chose de condamnable
par exemple quelqu'un qui aurait commis
un vol
et imaginer que cette personne qui a
commis un vol vous la connaissez mais
vous ne l'aimez pas
pour des raisons qui vous regarde
parce que vous n'aimez pas sa tête ou
parce que vous avez un vieux contentieux
peu importe
bon bah qu'est ce que vous allez dire à
propos de cette personne que vous
n'aimez pas et qui a commis un vol
là vous allez dire tout le mal que vous
en pensez
vous allez dire c'est honteux c'est une
crapule
il a pas d'unité
bref tout le florilège
c'est ça que vous allez dire
on n'aurait pas c'est
maintenant imaginer que cette personne
ce n'est plus quelqu'un que vous n'aimez
pas
contraire quelqu'un que vous aimez
quelqu'un pour qui vous avez de
l'estiment
lorsqu'à là qu'est ce que vous allez
dire
peut-être que vous allez tenir
exactement le même discours
mais il est beaucoup plus probable que
vous nuancier vos propos
que vous disiez mince mais pourquoi est
ce qu'il a fait ça
il doit y avoir une raison
sans doute ils étaient dans le besoin
sans doute c'était une question de vie
ou de mort
et puis est ce qu'on est bien sûr que
c'est lui qui a commis ce vol
est-ce qu'on a des preuves
et puis un vol c'est pas si grave
y'a pas mort d'homme
voyez ce genre de situation les
situations l'asymétrie
ce qu'on appelle vraiment deux poids
deux mesures
deux poids deux mesures ça veut dire
qu'on ne va pas être neutre dans notre
jugement
on ne va pas être impartial
dans un cas on va vouloir enfoncer la
personne
on va vouloir occulter les circonstances
pour pouvoir la charger au maximum
et dans l'autre cas on va vouloir
comprendre
on va vouloir atténuer
on va vouloir
contextualiser
autres m'ont dit on va faire preuve
d'une complaisance qu'on jugerait
déplacer si quelqu'un faisait preuve de
cette même complaisance à l'égard de la
personne qu'on aime pas
et bien c'est ça la mauvaise foi
c'est la mauvaise foi parce que c'est
une adaptation du discours à nos
intérêts
je n'ai pas intérêt à blâmer quelqu'un
pour qui j'ai de l'estimé
parce qu'alors les devoir me justifier
intérieurement d'avoir de l'estimé pour
quelqu'un de condamnable
alors que quelqu'un que je n'aime pas
j'ai au contraire intérêt à le blâmer
parce que ça confortera l'opinion que
j'ai de cette personne
on appelle ça le jugement motivé
jugement motivé c'est quand on ne juge
pas sur pièce
mais à partir de la conclusion qu'on
aura préalablement choisi de défendre
le jugement motivé ces cantons mais la
conclusion en amont du jugement
et qu'on élabore tout un scénario
argumentatif pour justifier ce qu'on
n'irait jamais justifié dans une autre
situation
c'est ça l'épicentre de la mauvaise foi
le jugement motivé
et là où le jugement motivé se fait
ressentir avec le plus de force c'est
quand il nous concerne
quand il nous concerne nous
quand c'est nous qui sommes la cible
d'un jugement ont réagi différemment que
quand c'est l'autre qui est la cible
d'un jugement
et c'est là que sera prononcé la fameuse
phrase oui mais moins c'est pas pareil
toi aussi tu as commis un vol oui mais
moi c'est pas pareil
ah bon c'est pas pareil et pourquoi
c'est pas pareil
pourquoi
parce que c'est moi
et moi c'est pas pareil
voyez ce réseau circulaire
c'est pas pareil quand c'est moi parce
que quand c'est moi c'est pas pareil
on s'en sort pas
et celui qui se justifie en disant c'est
pas pareil il ne se sent pas du tout en
train de mentir
il ne se sent pas du tout de mauvaise
foi
il pense sincèrement que c'est pas
pareil
et s'il le pense sincèrement c'est parce
que la mauvaise foi consiste justement à
détourner les yeux de son propre
mensonge
la mauvaise foi c'est trouver des
raisons quand on a besoin de raisons
et c'est ne pas trouvé de raison quand
on ne veut pas trouvé de raison
ne pas vous deux raisons c'est vouloir
qu'il n'y ait pas de raison
parce qu'une bonne raison risquerait de
nous obliger à nuancer un jugement qu'on
n'a pas du tout envie de nuancer
parce que ce n'est pas dans notre
intérêt
c'est dans son sac il faut entendre le
mot intérêts
l'intérêt qu'on défend à travers la
mauvaise foi ce n'est pas un intérêt
matériel
c'est un intérêt psycho symbolique
c'est un intérêt en terme d' affecté de
représentation
et c'est ce qui fait que dès lors qu'il
y a de l'affect en jeu le jugement n'est
plus neutre
le jugement n'est jamais neutre
il est l'extension de l'affect
il est la forme des eaux risée de
l'affect
comme dit sénèque l'arrêt
si des ce qui est juste
l'émotion veut qu'on trouve juste ce
qu'elle a décidé
quand on est sous l'emprise d'un affect
on devient cet affect
et en devenant cet affect on ne voit
plus l'affect
on se confond avec lui
la mauvaise foi c'est là
notre fusion avec l'affect
c'est la traduction de notre incapacité
à décoller la raison de l'affect
beaucoup de gens pensent que la raison
peut s'émanciper de l'affect
ils diront si on regarde les choses de
manière factuelle
mais enfin écoutez bien l'absurdité
si on regarde de manière factuelle
comment peut-on regarder de manière
factuelle
un regard c'est le contraire d'un fait
un regard ça suppose un angle sous
lequel on regarde
ça suppose une perspective sous laquelle
on regarde
et c'est cette croyance dans la
neutralité de nos jugements qui conduit
à ce qu'on appelle en psychologie la
dissonance cognitive
la dissonance cognitive
c'est une contradiction entre les faits
et notre système de croyances
c'est une contradiction entre la réalité
et nos attentes vis-à-vis de cette
réalité
et donc la dissonance cognitive nous
conduit à des stratégies d'évitement
on réécrit l'histoire
reconstruit la réalité pour faire
coïncider la réalité avec nos intérêts
et c'est ce qui fait que la mauvaise foi
entraîne des conflits
parce que si principe que la réalité est
la même pour tous quelqu'un qui
transforme la réalité pour la faire
coller à son système de croyances bah ça
énerve
ça énerve celui qui est de mauvaise foi
qui sent bien que la réalité menace son
système de croyances
et ses nerfs celui qui constate la
mauvaise foi
qui a juste l'impression
d'être pris pour un con
mais si on admet que la réalité n'est
pas la même pour tous
au sens où la réalité c'est d'abord
l'expérience subjective que nous avons
de la réalité
si on admet qu'on se construit
mentalement la réalité dont on a besoin
pour pouvoir vivre et fonctionner avec
son système de croyances
alors on comprend qu'à la mauvaise foi
est une fatalité
on n'est pas de mauvaise foi pour le
plaisir
on est une mauvaise foi par stratégies
de survie
dans la mauvaise forme
l'affect détermine la pensée
l'intérêt détermine la pensée
et notre
chic premier c'est le besoin de
cohérence
le besoin de cohérence c'est ce qui
assure l'équilibré et la stabilité de
notre système identitaire
qu'est ce que j'appelle le système
identitaire
six thèmes identitaires
l'ensemble des croyances et des valeurs
par lesquels on se définit
par lesquels on se définit auprès des
autres mais aussi par lesquels on se
définit auprès de soi même
il faut surtout pas sous-estimer
l'importance de l'image de soi
de l'image de soi auprès de soi
il ya plus important que le jugement
d'autrui sur nous il y a notre jugement
du jugement d'autrui sur nous
on donne au jugement d'autrui
la valeur que ce jugement a pour nous
et donc tout l'enjeu de la mauvaise foi
c'est de maintenir notre image de soi
auprès de nous mêmes
par exemple
si vous voulez ici c'est comme quelqu'un
de courageux
et que vous tenez à ce qualificatif pour
vous définir et j'insiste sur le verbe
tenir
bien dans ce cas larmes il vous sera
très difficile d'admettre que vous ayez
pu à un moment donné faire preuve de
lâcheté
parce qu'alors vous vous trouverez en
contradiction avec votre système
identitaire
et donc si quelqu'un vous fais remarquer
que vous avez fait preuve de lâcheté et
qu'au fond de vous vous savez qu'il n'a
peut-être pas totalement tort vous
n'allez pas l'accepter
vous ne pourrez pas l'accepter
vous ne pourrez pas l'accepter parce que
vous aurez tellement misé sur le fait
que vous étiez quelqu'un de courageux
que si du jour au lendemain cet élément
de votre identité venait à s'effondrer
vous ne seriez plus vous même
vous ne seriez plus rien
donc vous allez être de mauvaise foi
vous allez dire par exemple que la
personne n'a rien compris
ou vous allez lui retourner la critique
vous allez déployer toute une rhétorique
argumentative pour lui prouver qu'elle a
tort et que vous avez raison
parce qu'il y va de votre sentiment de
cohérence
parce qu'il y va de la représentation
que vous vous êtes construite de vous
même
et qu'à partir du moment où on s'est
construit une représentation de soi même
il n'est plus question d'en changer
ce serait comme détruire ce qu'on a
passé toute sa vie à construire
c'est coûteux
donc qu'est ce que vous allez faire vous
allez
rationaliser
rational c'est à dire que vous allez
réagencer la réalité par le discours
pour montrer que votre comportement
était en réalité parfaitement légitime
et appropriées
dont vous allez vous accrochés aux
branches vous allez faire les acrobaties
avec la logique parce que l'important
n'est pas la vérité
l'important est le sentiment de
cohérence
l'important c'est l'illusion de la
donc non vous n'avez pas été lâche
jamais de la vie
et ceux qui soutiennent le contraire ce
sont eux qui sont de mauvaise foi
la mauvaise foi c'est une balle de ping
pong
vous êtes attaché à la vérité vous
prenez la franchise vous prônez la
sincérité la transparence
et pourtant il vous arrive tir
problème
comment justifier de mentir quand on a
fait de la franchise un élément central
de son système identitaire
c'est contradictoire
et donc pour résoudre cette
contradiction on va mobiliser une
stratégie par exemple le contexte
j'ai menti oui mais parce que le
contexte l'exigé
j'ai menti parce que je n'avais pas le
choix
et si je n'avais pas le choix et bien
moi mensonges n'en est plus totalement
et
je n'ai pas vraiment menti
j'ai composé avec les circonstances
et si on est assez habile
intellectuellement on arrivera
sincèrement à se convaincre que ces
incohérences ne sont pas
on arrivera à sincèrement à se
convaincre qu'il n'ya pas de
contradiction entre le fait de se
définir comme quelqu'un d'attaché à la
vérité et le fait de mentir ouvertement
par contre si c'est l'autre jeu surprend
en train de mentir
alors là il n'a aucune excuse
il ne peut pas voir
lui trouver une excuse ce serait
considérer que ce que je prône comme une
valeur fondamentale de mon système
identitaire n'a en fait pas de valeur
et ça c'est pas possible
c'est très important de comprendre ça
parce que tout part de là
tout part du système identitaire et de
ce qu'on est prêt à faire pour maintenir
sa stabilité
je disais tout à l'heure que si une
faille apparaissait dans notre système
identitaire
autrement dit si une incohérence venait
à s'établir entre notre représentation
nous mêmes et la réalité notre
comportement notre équilibre psychique
était en péril
car alors nous ne sommes plus que nous
prétendons être
et là on touche au coeur de l'analyse de
sartre sur la mauvaise foi
est ce que nous dit sartre c'est que
nous avons besoin d'une représentation
nous mêmes
nous avons besoin d'une identité par
laquelle nous définir
en ce sens nous sommes tous des
essentialiste qui s'ignorent
des platonicien s'ignorent
parce que pour platon au delà des choses
qui sont dans notre bas monde
il y à l'essence des choses
et l'essence d'une chose elle fx
elle est
immuable
si une chose person essence n existe
plus
elle n'est plus soutenu par rien
et bien la même son nous nous donnons
une essence
nous définissons selon cette essence
et cette essence devient notre raison
d'être
on a vu quelques exemples tout à l'heure
se définir comme courageux se définir
comme attachée à la vérité
tout ça ce sont des essences
et peu importe que ces essences ne
correspondent pas à la réalité
ce qui compte c'est de s'identifier à
une essence
parce qu'au fond ce qu'on exprime à
travers la mauvaise foi ce n'est pas
tant la peur d'avoir tort
c'est la peur de ne plus savoir qui on
est
c'est la peur de ne plus être rien
ce qu'on redoute
c'est la désagrégation de notre identité
c'est l'anéantissement
du mois
sartre feu tim du courant
existentialiste
on a déjà eu l'occasion d'expliquer ce
qu'était l'existentialisme donc je vais
simplement me contenter d'un bref rappel
l'existentialisme c'est la vision selon
laquelle l'être humain est le seul
maître de son existence
autrement dit
selon laquelle nous sommes
tellement libre de choisir ce que nous
sommes
l'existentialisme s'oppose à de courant
il s'oppose à l'essentialisme
ils s'opposent également au déterminisme
et si on arrive à prendre cette double
opposition
si on arrive à comprendre en quoi la
vision existentialiste est à la fois un
anti essentialisme est un anti
déterminisme on comprendra du même coup
en quoi l'être humain est pour ainsi
dire
prédisposé à la mauvaise foi
alors d'abord l'essentialisme
l'essentialisme comme son nom l'indiqué
c'est l'idée selon laquelle les êtres
humains posséderait une essence
autrement dit qu'il possèderait une
nature dont ils ne pourraient pas
s'affranchir
avoir une essence c'est avoir une
identité figée
on a vu que la mauvaise foi repose
justement sur cette tendance de l'homme
à essentialiser
on devrait dire
soto essentialiser
on se donne une nature courageux sincère
et à partir de cette nature ont réécrit
notre récit existentielle
et
sartre c'est que cette essentialisation
est le fruit de notre angoisse
pourquoi
parce qu essentialiser c'est donner des
contours aux choses
l'identité fonctionne sur le principe de
l'essentialisation
quand les choses sont identifiables
elles sont maîtrisables
on peut se repérer grâce à elle
et en se donnant une identité
on se soulage de l' angoisse liée à
l'indétermination
remarqué comme l'inquiétude se nourrit
de l'indétermination
elle se nourrit de l'inconnu
plus les choses soins fini plus on est
inquiet
plus elles sont définies plus on est
rassuré
et c'est d'autant plus la bhl pour nous
êtres humains
parce qu'à bien y regarder
nous sommes ce qu'il y a de plus
indéterminée
saissac d'audi l'existentialisme
l'être humain est fondamentalement
indéterminée
sartre va encore plus loin il dit
l'être humain n'est rien
il n'est rien parce que son être se
confond avec ses choix
sont lettres se confond avec ses actions
et chacune de nos actions est un
arrachement au néant
en agissant ont choisi un chemin parmi
une infinité de chemins possibles
et à voir ans de st avoir conscience du
néant fondamental de notre condition
originelle
c'est entrer dans l' angoisse
se donner une essence c'est se donner
une consistance
c'est remplir le néant de notre identité
d'un rôle qui nous permet non seulement
de savoir qui on est mais de le
proclamer au monde
étant entendu que plus on a besoin de
proclamer son essence au monde
plus on fait la démonstration
de notre angoisse de n'être rien
asséné que l'on est si ou que l'on et ça
ça va besoin de le rappeler
de se le rappeler
est ce que nous dit sartre c'est qu'en
se donnant une essence on se comporte
comme si on était une simple chose
les choses ont une essence
elles ont une forme une fonction une
raison d'être
en ceux des en en se donnant une
identité un rôle à caractère
on se chausse hi fi
on se traite soi même comme une chose
et ce faisant on se donne la possibilité
de maîtriser notre essence
l'être humain être libre parce qu'il ne
veut pas être né en
il ne veut pas être
possibilité
l'être humain être quelque chose the
et ce quelque chose constitue pour lui
une garantie est de n'être pas rien
l'être humain soto défini
il s'auto essentialise pour échapper au
néant
mais comme je le disais
l'existentialisme ne se pose pas
seulement à l'essentialisme ils
s'opposent également au déterminisme
et le déterminisme
c'est l'idée que nous ne sommes pas
libres
parce que nous sommes le produit d'une
combinaison de causes et d'effets auquel
on ne peut pas se soustraire
le déterminisme ses dires par exemple je
suis comme ça parce qu'on environnement
m'a rendu comme ça
c'est dire je ne peux pas ça parce que
les conditions de vie ne me le
permettent pas
le déterminisme
c'est la négation notre pouvoir de
choisir notre condition
c'est donc là encore une manière de
rejeter notre liberté
de nier notre liberté
et c'est ça que sartre rappelle la
mauvaise foi
la mauvaise foi c'est la fuite vis-à-vis
de ce que nous sommes
à savoir des êtres libres
des êtres capables de ne pas se être
passivement au déterminisme
sartre ne pensait pas que le
déterminisme n'existait pas mais il
pensait qu'on ne pouvait pas imputer au
déterminisme la responsabilité de nos
choix
on peut rendre le déterminisme
responsables de ce qui arrive
mais on ne peut pas rendre le
déterminisme responsable de la manière
dont on réagit à ce qui arrive
c'est sa célèbre citation
n'importe parce qu'on a fait de nous
mais ce qu'on fait de ce qu'on a fait de
nous
parce que pour sartre l'être humain a
toujours le choix
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui différencie des
autres êtres de la nature
le choix
donc quand on parle de déterminisme à
propos de l'être humain ont réduit les
êtres humains à une chose parmi les
choses
ont fait d'être humain un être ganic
un être dépourvu de discernement
dépourvues de volonté
dépourvus science
on le déshumanise
on se déshumanise
et on accable le monde on accable le
contexte les lois sociologique
de notre propre lâcheté
en 1304
une truie fut condamné à mort pour avoir
dévoré le bras d'un enfant
il eu un procès à l'issue duquel la
truie fut reconnu coupable
on l'habille à d'une robe d'une veste de
grands
noms la conduisait à l'échafaud où elle
fut pendu devant la foule attroupée
on demanda même aux paysans de venir
voir l'exécution de la truie avec leurs
cochons
pour que cela leur serve de leçon
si cette histoire nous paraît grotesque
c'est pour une raison très simple
qui est qu'on ne peut raisonnablement
pas tenir une truie pour responsable de
ses actes
la responsabilité implique d'être doté
d'une raison
est ce que nous dit sartre c'est que si
on trouve absurde de tenir une truie
pour responsable de ses actes
on devrait trouver tout aussi absurde de
ne pas tenir l'être humain pour
responsable de ses actes
pour sartre c'est parce que l'être
humain est doté d'une conscience qu'il
est responsable de ses actes
et aucun des terres isme ne saurait
remettre ça en cause
sa trame ni évidemment pas que notre
comportement soit soumis à des
influences
bien sûr qu'il y a des influences
bien sûr qu'on ne fait pas exactement ce
qu'on voudrait comme on le voudrait
qui serait assez naïf pour le croire
est ce que dit sartre c'est que l'
influence ne signifie pas le
déterminisme
un corps inerte n'a pas le choix de ce
que vous lui fait subir
il obéit il obéit passivement
mais m ce n'est pas un corps inerte
la vision des thermes l'homme c'est la
vie de l'homme comme être
fondamentalement passif
comme être fondamentalement
mécanique
mais enfin dans ce cas là qu'est ce qui
différencie l'homme des choses inertes
qu'est ce qui différencie l'homme de
cette table de cette chaise de cette
lampe
qu'est ce qui différencie l'homme des
choses si ce n'est précisément la
liberté
est encore une fois être libre ça ne
veut pas dire être en apesanteur
ça ne veut pas dire flotter au dessus
des déterminations
ça veut dire avoir le dernier mot sur
les déterminations
ça veut dire être capable de dire oui ou
de dire non aux détermination
et la mauvaise foi c'est le fait de nier
ce pouvoir de l'homme
la mauvaise foi
s'est transformée l'être humain en
choses et l'existence en subsistance
je cite
il s'en suit d'abord que celui à qui
l'on ment et celui qui ment sont une
seule et même personne ce qui signifie
que je dois savoir en tant que trompeur
la vérité qui met masqué en tant que je
suis trompé mieux encore je dois savoir
très précisément cette vérité pour me
l'a caché plus soigneusement et ceci non
pas à deux moments différents de la
temporalité ce qui permettrait à la
rigueur de rétablir un semblant de
dualité mais dans la structure unitaire
d'un même projet comment donc le
mensonge peut-il subsistaient si la
dualité qui le conditionne est supprimé
à ces difficultés s'en ajoute une autre
qui dérive de la totale translucidité de
la conscience celui qui s'infectent de
mauvaise foi doit avoir conscience de sa
mauvaise foi puisque lettre de la
conscience et conscience d'être il
semble donc que je doive être de bonne
foi au moins en ceci que je suis
conscient de ma mauvaise foi mais alors
tout ce système si chic s'anéantit on
conviendra en effet que si j'ai c'est
délibérément et cyniquement de me mentir
j'échoue complètement dans cette
entreprise le mensonge recul et
s'effondre sous le regard il est ruiné
par derrière par la conscience même de
me mentir qui se constitue
impitoyablement en deçà de mon projet
comme sa condition même il y a là un
phénomène évanescent qui n'existe que
dans et par sa propre distinction certes
ces phénomènes sont fréquents et nous
verrons qu'il y a en effet une
évanescence de la mauvaise foi il est
évident qu'elle oscille perpétuellement
entre la bonne foi et le cynisme
toutefois si l'existence de la mauvaise
foi et fort précaire si elle appartient
à ce genre de structure psychique qu'on
pourrait appeler métastable elle n'en
présente pas moins une forme autonome et
durable elle peut même être l'aspect
normal de la vie pour un très grand
nombre de personnes on peut vivre dans
la mauvaise foi ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'on ait de brusque réveil de cynisme
ou de bonne foi mais ce qui implique un
style de constant et particulier notre
embarras semble donc extrême puisque
nous ne pouvons ni rejeter ni comprendre
la mauvaise foi
la mauvaise foi sartrienne c'est le
réflexe par lequel l'homme passif
revendique sa passivité
pour ne pas avoir à assumer sa
responsabilité
et sissach utilise l'expression de
mauvaise foi
c'est parce qu'ils considèrent que la
négation de notre responsabilité
correspond à la négation d'une vérité
de la seule vérité qui soit à savoir
que l'être humain est libre
non pas libres de ne plus subir une
influence
mais libre de ne pas se laisser
passivement transportés par les
influences
un bateau sur l'océan
c'est un bateau livré au déterminisme
il va être entraîné par les courants
même si sur ce bateau vous mettez un ten
qui tient le gouvernail
que vous mettez un équipage les ordres
alors le bateau cesse d'être le jouet du
déterminisme
le bateau c'est notre corps
le capitaine
c'est notre compte
l'équipage c'est la volonté
dirigé par la conscience
le bateau
n'est alors plus le jouet des vagues
il devient
l'adversaire des vagues
adversaires au sens littéral
ce qui fait parce
ce qui fait front
rappelons capitaine ça vient de kaputt
qui veut dire la tête
nous sommes les capitaines de notre
existence
être capitaine de son existence
ça suppose de ne pas détourner les yeux
du gouvernail
ça suppose de
regarder le gouvernail en face
et de dire
je suis le iten
je suis oui qui tient la barre
je suis celui qui
ne fuit pas
qui ne recule pas
j'existe
enfer d'où
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]